Hey there and welcome to Networking For
Web Developers.
In this course you'll learn a bunch
about how the internet works and
how applying that working knowledge can
help you make your web apps better.
As a web developer you may already know
a bit about HTTP, but you might not yet
know what it's built out of.
This course gives you a basic
understanding of the workings of
internet protocols.
Focused on the protocols
that underlie HTTP.
To get the most out of this course,
you should already be familiar with HTTP
itself, and also with using the Linux
shell, SSH and command line programs.
If you need a bit of
a refresher on those,
take a look back at the Audacity
courses in Linux Command Line Basics,
Configuring Linux Web Servers,
and Designing RESTful API's.
To do this course,
you'll need to log in to a Linux system.
If you're taking this course as part
of a Udacity nanodegree program,
you can use the development
instance that we've set up for you.
In case you lost track of it, there's
a link to it in the instruction notes.
Otherwise, you can use
a real Linux server, or
you can set up a virtual machine
that runs on your regular computer.
See the instructor notes for
a link on how to do that.
Next up, I'm going to give you some
written instructions on how to install
the tools you'll need for
this course on your Linux system.